merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation pour échanger
sur la question importante de l'eau nous
avons donc fait cette audition avec les
offices de l'eau et nous avons invité
aussi l'ensemble des sénateurs et
sénatrices
d'outre-mer mais je crois qu'il y a une
réunion en même temps au ministère de
non c'est annulé donc
on a
peut-être quelques sénateurs et
sénatrices qui vont nous rejoindre
dans cette pour cette audition et ça il
y aura donc un compte rendu un public
l'objectif c'est d'éclairer les membres
de la mission d'information
sur la gestion durable de l'eau qui
était lancée par le Sénat début février
c'est une mission transpartizane comme
on a l'habitude de le faire au Sénat et
à la demande du groupe socialiste avec
comme rapporteur mon collègue Hervé
gilet
sénateur de Gironde
et cette mission donc je préside qu'on
prend des sénateurs représentant
l'ensemble des groupes politiques et
devrait donc achever ces travaux début
juillet
dans ce temps un peu raccourci il s'agit
d'entendre de ton que les experts les
parties prenantes les acteurs
institutionnels de la politique de l'eau
en France et bien évidemment notre
intérêt de se limite pas uniquement la
France métropolitaine et on a souhaité
aussi mettre l'accent bien évidemment
sur les enjeux hydriques des Outre-mer
compte tenu des spécificités qui peuvent
être liées selon les territoires à
l'insularité à l'absence de masse d'eau
souterraines ou à l'exposition forte aux
effets du changement climatique ou à la
vétusté ou au maillage insuffisant des
réseaux de distribution avec souvent des
canalisations
fuyardes à la salinité des ressources
disponibles et puis voir aussi parfois
la pression
démographique ou touristique qui conduit
à la mise en place de Tours d'eau entre
les uns et les autres
il s'agit donc pour nous d'évaluer la
pertinence de la politique publique de
l'eau qui est menée aujourd'hui dans les
outre-mer tant sur ces aspects
quantitatifs que qualitatifs
donc on souhaiterait bien sûr savoir
est-ce que les objectifs
sont adaptés est-ce que la compagnement
de l'État est suffisant est-ce que les
instruments juridiques organisationnels
ou encore financier de la politique de
l'eau sont efficaces et efficients
est-ce que le cadre fixé par les grandes
lois sur l'eau de 64 de 92 et de 2006
doit-il évoluer et notamment vers une
différenciation accrue au bénéfice des
outre-mer et puis qu'est-ce qu'il faut
changer pour mieux gérer l'eau dans les
territoires ultramarins au regard de
leur contrainte particulière et voir
aussi quels sont vos préoccupations
donc je sais que un questionnaire vous a
été adressé
ça va servir de tram à notre entretien
et je souhaite que vous puissiez
éventuellement nous adresser à la suite
de cette audition une contribution
écrite qui nous permettra de bien
fléchés toutes les discussions que nous
pourrons avoir dans les minutes qui
suivent donc voilà je sais que Monsieur
Dominique labande directeur de l'office
de l'eau de la Guadeloupe que je vois
présent
je vois aussi
bonjour monsieur Fayçal Bada directeur
du développement durable des territoires
adjoints auprès du directeur général de
l'Office de l'eau de la Réunion
bonjour
madame Myriam in mode
directrice responsable du pôle technique
territorial de l'office de l'eau de la
Guyane
non je sais pas
Madame Michelin Adin
directrice générale de l'office de l'eau
de la Martinique je l'aperçu un instant
Leroux adjoint au chef de service
environnement et prévention des risques
à la de Mayotte
je sais pas si
vous êtes en ligne
et je mets à mes côtés donc Stéphane
Artano
président
de la délégation d'outre-mer et ma
collègue Micheline Jack qui est
également présente
donc merci encore à vous et je vais
laisser la parole à mon collègue Hervé
gilet
bien bonjour bonsoir à vous toutes et à
vous tous en vous renouvelant nos
remerciements pour votre disponibilité
le président Rémy Cointreau a donné le
cadre général de cette mission
d'information en mettant en exergue déjà
les premiers questionnements généraux
vous concernant je vous propose tout
d'abord peut-être
de vous laisser un peu de temps
justement pour faire une une première
présentation
des structures que vous représentez dans
le cadre de cette audition et puis de
pouvoir nous apporter déjà les premiers
commentaires
et réponses concernant les questions de
fond que le président pointeau a pu
exprimer et je reviendrai dans un
deuxième temps sur les questions un peu
plus précises mais qui vont suivre bien
sûr le questionnaire qui vous a été
transmis et nos collègues présents bien
évidemment pour pourront échanger avec
vous donc je vous donne la parole et on
démarre peut-être par Monsieur Laban
oui bonjour bonjour à tous donc
Dominique Lamon directeur de l'office de
Ludo Guadeloupe c'est une établissement
public qui est rattaché à la
collectivité des parents mentale puisque
comme vous le savez on Guadeloupe on a
toujours la coexistence d'une région de
département et le fils de l'eau de
Guadeloupe est présidé par Madame
Isabelle
donc on intervient sur un territoire
archipel avec une double insularité et
sur les problématiques de l'eau que vous
avez évoqué
on considère alors on est passé depuis
l'année 2021 de 5 autorités
avec la création de l'instruction unique
de l'eau le smgag et la communauté de
communes de Marie-Galante alors par
rapport aux questions que vous avez
posées sur l'improvisionnement eau
potable
la disponibilité de la ressource la
pollution etc
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
[Musique]
l'état du réseau la principale
difficulté à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés depuis de nombreuses années
c'est la vétusté du réseau on a un
réseau qui est ordin on a des
canalisations et des conduites qui
datent de plus de 80 ans qui sont en
cours de renouvellement et depuis la
mise en oeuvre du plan Odom au cours des
cinq dernières années il y a eu un
sérieux effort d'investissement sur le
renouvellement de ces réseaux sur la
remise en état d'unité de production et
donc
ce qu'on constate c'est que
ce réseau est fragile
du réseau a été mise en évidence à
l'occasion du passage de la récente
tempête Fiona qui a
endommagé une partie du feeder de
capacité à vélo qui est le principal de
réseau qui alimente l'ensemble de d'une
partie de consommateur en eau de grande
air des Saintes et de désirable alors
c'est un réseau qu'il faut entièrement
renouvelés pour une grande partie
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
par rapport à la disponibilité de la
ressource
nous on a noté depuis quelques années
une augmentation significative des
volumes prélevés et on considère qu'il y
a une surexploitation de la ressource on
prélève environ 120 millions de mètres
cubes de par an dans les
principalement dans les eaux
superficielles des rivières et les cours
d'eau et que malheureusement
50% de ces prélèvements sont perdus on a
la moitié du réseau qui est vétuste et
qui alimente un nombre élevé de suite
une exploitation aussi dans les eaux
souterraines de grandes terres
on s'est rendu compte dans le suivi de
la directive cadre européenne que avec
le DRGM il y a une synchronisation de
certains forages et que en commentaire
la salinisation devenue irréversible
donc il y a manifestement une
surexploitation de la ressource
alors
cette ressource elle est impactée par
les effets du dérèglement climatique on
a eu il y a pas très longtemps une
période de sécheresse qui a nécessité
un apport supplémentaire d'eau
principalement pour les agriculteurs de
grandes terres
à ce titre ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la collectivité départementale qui a mis
en place une politique d'irrigation avec
des barrages a permis de compenser le
besoin en eau des agriculteurs mais
les effets du dérèglement climatique
nous amène à considérer qu'il faut de
plus en plus gérer de façon beaucoup
plus responsable
cette ressource parce que les tomber
sont dirigés en mode de gestion sur des
zones très sensibles principalement sur
la zone de compter
on a insisté à multiplication de
dispositifs de stockage d'eau soit des
eaux pluviales soit d'eau potable y
compris dans les écoles et dans les
établissements recevant du public et que
l'achat de bouteille représente un cours
exemple 8 ans pour les minima sociaux
parce que ça représente un budget qui
est quand même conséquent dans une
période d'inflation et d'augmentation
des maintiens première et notamment du
coup du terme de
on est confronté à des problèmes de
pollution qui sont connues notamment
ceux liés aux pesticides avec
le plan d'école
il y a aussi des pollutions
industrielles
notamment avec les pollutions générales
par les producteurs de Rome et les
distilleries mais l'activité économique
qui se développe aussi sur la zone
industrielle de Jarry et on commence
aussi à être sérieusement impacté par
les choix des Sargasses avec des
pollutions qui sont qui ont des impacts
sur l'environnement notamment sur le
milieu côtier
alors depuis le plan d'homme comme je
l'ai dit il y a quelques années il y a
une maquette financière qui a été mise
en place par l'État qui était de 35
millions d'euros
qui n'était pas suffisant au regard de
la volumétrie des investissements
réalisés pour réhabiliter les
dispositifs de potable et qui a été
complété par un plan d'action
prioritaire qui a été piloté par la
région de département
et là il y a eu un sérieux coup
d’accélération sur la réhabilitation des
réseaux du linéaire de réseau sur la
réparation de fuite sur le changement de
compteur et donc oui il y a une
amélioration mais qui n'est pas
suffisante parce que
[Musique]
si on prend considération les
contraintes générés par un inconformité
des dispositifs des prévention qui
atteignent un niveau très élevé on a
globalement 80% des dispositifs
d'épurations qui sont non conformes
cela tout cela génère une volumétrie
financière qui est quand même
conséquente qui est de l'ordre 800
millions d'euros pour l'eau et un peu
plus pour l'assainissement
donc le fiston d'eau a bien évidemment
apporté sa contribution
aux travaux de rattrapage indispensable
pour remédier à aux mauvais état du
réseau aux conduites et aux
canalisations
l'Office a réalisé schéma
exhaustif sur l'inventaire du patrimoine
des réseaux 2 et des séismes qui a été
mis à disposition du smgagé qui lui
permet d'avoir une meilleure lisibilité
de l'état des réseaux et des points de
sensibilité sur lesquels il est urgent
d'intervenir et donc ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que on subit malheureusement les
effets de des ruptures en eau potable
principalement pour des catégories
sociales défavorisées et c'est un vrai
préjudice qui devient à certains
endroits insupportables
merci Monsieur Laban
on va poursuivre donc à la fois la
présentation
et les réactions première par rapport
aux questions posées peut-être avec
Madame Myriam inimode
alors tarin d'accord donc Madame Michela
Adam
alors bonjour
je crois que j'ai remis mon écran
très bien
merci alors pour la Martinique l'office
de l'eau Martinique c'est une équipe de
30 agents donc on est sur un budget
annuel d'environ 12 millions
nous sommes
donc nous exerçons sur toute la
compétence tout le territoire et nous
sommes effectivement des observateurs
clés contenus de la mission
de développement de la connaissance et
de l'information que nous avons
alors que dire pour être très
synthétique sur deux en deux plans
concernant l'eau potable donc on peut
dire qu'en Martinique on n'a pas de
souci concernant la ressource en eau
elle est abondante
même si
certaines alertes sont posées et nous
devons être béatifs par rapport à notre
manière de consommer à l'aune du
changement climatique il pleut beaucoup
en Martinique et
99,9% des Martiniquais ont accès à l'eau
potable par contre les réseaux sont
fuyard nous avons
un souci de rendement donc avec un taux
de rendement qui est assez faible à peu
près 40% en moyenne alors tout le
territoire n'est pas uniforme
nous donc ça veut dire qu'on prélève
trop par rapport aux besoins de la
population
nous observons également une baisse de
la consommation c'est une tendance une
tendance longue mais avec un des
changements de comportement
concernant l'eau nous avons une
particularité c'est que elle est mal
répartie dans l'espace géographiques le
nord de la Martinique
concentre la
totalité je veux dire non et centre de
la réserve en eau naturelle et des
massifs forestiers donc les principaux
captages sont situés dans le Nord alors
que le Sud
n'a pas d'eau de points de captage donc
on a une problématique d'amener l'eau du
Nord vers le Sud sachant que le sud et
le sang de la Martinique notamment le
sud sont les zones les plus les plus
peuplées
à côté de cette problématique
géographique il y a une problématique de
temporalité de saisonnalité
puisque nous faisons face de manière
assez régulière à des périodes de
sécheresse très fortes pendant la
période sèche qu'on appelle chez nous
carême
Carême qui va de descendre à
juin je dirais
ces périodes nous semblent de plus en
plus longues paraissent de plus en plus
longue et de plus en plus sévère l'une
des plus sévères ces dernières années
c'était 2020 mais là sur 2023 nous avons
déjà des alertes
qui ne sont pas très bonnes alors que
nous sommes au mois de mai
[Musique]
la sécheresse est en train de
s'installer on a l'impression que la
période s'annonce de plus en plus
ensuite
donc
concernant concernant
l'assainissement d'un autre côté
l'assainissement là on est voilà sur une
bombe à retardement la Martinique est
bien équipée en
installation en équipement en usine de
traitement donc davantage qu'un problème
d'équipement ou de comment
d'investissement dans du neuf nous avons
une problématique
d'amélioration de la performance des
exploitations pour ce qui concerne
l'assainissement collectif
nous avons une moyenne de 15% de
conformité toute cause confondue il peut
y avoir des conformités effectivement
qui paraissent légère administrative
mais en tout cas 15% de conformité c'est
pas suffisant donc ces stations parfois
fonctionnent mal parce que ils sont pas
bien entretenus soit sous dimensionné ou
au contraire surdimensionné
concernant l'assainissement non
collectif
il faut noter que ça concerne 60% du
parc
est en assainissement collectif donc en
fosse septique dans ces 60% vous avez à
peu près 85% de nos conformités
s'agissant de l'assainissement non
collectif pour nous c'est une vraie
problématique puisque les maîtres
d'ouvrage sont des personnes
des personnes privées dans leur maison
sachant que nous avons évalué une le
coût d'une réhabilitation pour une
conformité
au sens national est en moyenne de 10000
euros entre 10000 et 12000 euros et la
sociologie de la population ne permet
pas en général aux personnes de faire
face à ces frais et donc ça me permet de
glisser sur la problématique de la
pollution l'assainissement en Martinique
c'est
comment la cause numéro une de la
pollution de nos masses d'eau notamment
de nos masses d'eau côtière nous sommes
sur des bassins très petits donc avec
des effets en côte très rapidement
l'état des lieux de 2018-2019 la poser
comme observation le stage convient de
voter 2022-2027 le pose en priorité
avec des sommes d'argent
conséquentes mais l'argent ne suffit pas
nous avons également un vrai travail de
sensibilisation et
au niveau de la population et c'est ce
que nous essayons de faire à l'office de
l'eau avec un certain nombre de
dispositifs bien sûr de financement du
public mais également de manière un peu
plus originale de financement du privé
puisque nous avons mis en place ce qu'on
a appelé un dessin des FAP à dispositif
de financement
pour l'assainissement des particuliers
et donc nous ne faisons pas cette
démarche seule nous sommes allés
chercher des partenaires sociaux
enfin qui agissent sur le secteur social
c'est-à-dire la CGSS la CAF
mais également la CTM la collectivité
territoriale de Martinique donc pour
essayer de venir en aide en aide à ces
personnes privées
bien évidemment
la pollution peut pas ne pas parler de
l'accordéon en Martinique peut-être que
le territoire Martinique est le plus
emblématique parce que le plus couvert
de bananerais historiquement et donc
à l'odeur nous suivons 150 indicateurs
c'est à dire qu'en plus des indicateurs
DCE directives Cado nous suivons un
certain nombre d'indicateurs locaux
qui nous permettent d'avoir une approche
très précise et très comment je peux
dire ça spécifique très territorialisée
des
auxquelles nous faisons face bien
évidemment
tout ce qui concerne les distillerie
nous apportons une attention
particulière et nous suivons ces
entreprises là en sorte qu'elles
puissent modifier leur leur comportement
je vais pas trop longues juste dire que
sur la Sargasses nous faisons partie des
différents groupes de travail
en Martinique un GIP vient d'être monté
à l'initiative de la CTM
nous prenons notre part en développement
de la connaissance en financement
également de l'investissement
je vais dire que la compétence en
Martinique est répartie entre trois EPCI
Nord centre issus donc il y a une
lecture assez simple de la compétence
ces EPCI ont pris ces compétences assez
récemment ça date de 2017
pour deux d'entre elles et de 2014 ou en
tout cas c'est un petit peu plus ancien
pour la Kacem enfin par rapport à une
politique publique c'est assez récent et
c'est ces OPCI n'ont pas les moyens de
leurs besoins d'investissement nous
sommes sur quand même la plupart du
temps dans le cadre du Plan d'homme sur
de l'investissement à 85% voire quatre
avoir 100%, tout le fond public réunis
malgré ça elles ont des soucis lorsqu'il
reste 5% de fonds propres à pouvoir
décaisser ses fonds propres elle
rencontre également des problématiques
d'ingénierie interne
les équipes techniques ne sont pas
suffisantes ne sont pas assez nombreuses
sur un territoire sur la CASEM voilà
au-dessus qui est l'opérateur public je
sais pas si on peut compter deux
ingénieurs dans l'équipe technique donc
c'est un peu compliqué en gros les
financements ne trouvent pas les projets
alors les besoins en investissement
existe les projets sont listés mais les
projets n'arrivent pas à avoir le jour
compte tenu de certains nombre de
paramètres dont le manque d'ingénierie à
l'intérieur des collectivités donc
davantage qu'un problème de financement
puisque un certain nombre de dispositifs
le collègue en a parlé Dominique là-bas
en a parlé que ce soit le plan d'homme
le plan relancetta
comment le plan d'urgence
après la sécheresse de 2020 mais
également les dispositifs ode les
financements sont là l'odeur coordonne
un comité de pilota un comité des
financeurs qui regroupe tous les
financeurs locaux
mais par contre les projets ne sort pas
que ce soit en assainissement ou en eau
potable il faut dire aussi que nous
sommes toujours en attente des schémas
que ce soit sur l'eau potable que ce
soit sur la les schémas n'existent pas
voilà je m'arrête là il y en a beaucoup
de choses à dire mais j'essaie d'être
synthétique ou vous brossez un petit peu
une situation
je crois que Madame Myriam et nimode est
en ligne
bonjour
je suis connecté un peu tardivement
petit problème de connexion non
on va
prendre monsieur Leroux
oui bonsoir Olivier Cremer le directeur
de la DL de Mayotte
vous m'entendez bien oui
alors pour ce qui est de Mayotte donc
nous n'avons pas d'office de l'eau sur
Mayotte puisque pour l'instant la
structure n'a pas été créé donc nous
répartissons l'émission de l'office de
l'eau entre
l'adéal le syndicat mixte et l'ofb sur
le territoire
voilà pour la situation
telle qu'elle est en termes
d'organisation
sur pour répondre à vos questions sur
les problématiques de l'eau potable
alors nous sommes dans une situation
effectivement très délicate cette année
sur Mayotte puisque
en dehors de la période de crise que
nous vivons actuellement nous avons une
tension permanente sur la ressource en
eau sur le territoire puisque cette
ressource en nous elle provient
majoritairement de des pluies et des
capacités avec les revenus colinéaires
qui soient existants sur le territoire
cette année la situation est d'autant
plus tendue que nous n'avons quasiment
pas eu de saison des pluies donc saison
des pluies qui est prévu en début
d'année et qui permet justement de
reconstituer la nappe phréatique et de
pouvoir remplir les revenus colinaires
alors actuelle alors que les autres
années nous étions à nous retenus
colinaires qui étaient entièrement
remplis voire même qu'il est bordé nous
ne sommes qu'à à peu près 40% de notre
de nos revenus colinéaires qui sont
remplis
sur le territoire donc ce double
problème qu'on a à la fois disponibilité
de la ressource en eau liée à cette
saison des pluies déficitaires et des
capacités de production
insuffisantes nous permet de
difficilement de répondre à la demande
donc nous avons mis en place avec le
syndicat
ici
des des tours d'eau actuellement qui
sont des tours d'eau nocturnes et que
nous allons très certainement augmenté
dans
[Musique]
quelques jours
pour répondre à ça
on a
on a actuellement plusieurs pistes sur
lequel on travaille on travaille à la
fois sur bien évidemment les recherches
de fuite qui sont qui sont présentes
mais qui peuvent être relativement moins
importantes que celles qu'on peut
connaître sur d'autres drones on
travaille également sur l'optimisation
des forages qu'on est en train de
réaliser et on accélère les
investissements qui doivent être
réalisés donc des investissements qui
sont identifiés dans une programmation
pluriannuelle
2022-2026 qui prévoit justement la mise
en oeuvre des nouveaux forages des
unités mobiles de traitement une
nouvelle usine de dessalement située sur
grand air puisque actuellement nous en
avons une qui est sur Petite Terre et
une réflexion sur une troisième revenu
colinéaire au titre par exemple des
investissements sur l'eau potable le
montant de la PPI qui est prévu dans les
investissements et de 287 millions
d'euros sur 2022 2026
nous avons également bien évidemment des
des préoccupations en matière
d'assainissement puisque le territoire
est en retard vis-à-vis des obligations
fixées par la
dérue pour les agglomérations plus de
10000 équivalents d'habitants en 2020
c'est pour ça que là aussi dans la PPI
de 2022 2026 on intègre à voler
l'assainissement prévoyant l'objectif
justement de respecter ses obligations
pour les six agglomérations qui sont
concernés avec les plus de 10000
équivalents habitants avec des enjeux
sanitaires environnementaux qui sont
importants et résoudre aussi les
situations d'urgence face à l'impact aux
impacts environnementaux forts qu'on
peut connaître sur le territoire
l'appareil sur la PPI 2022 2026 sur le
volet assainissement on prévoit un total
d'investissement de 181 millions d'euros
pour notre territoire
donc face à ça
il y a une très forte mobilisation
au niveau au niveau local avec à la fois
une gestion de crise immédiate qui est
centrée sur une répartition équitable de
la ressource sur l'ensemble du
territoire tout en compte de
l'anticipation des risques sanitaires et
et en mettant en place des plans de
travaux d'augmentation des ressources en
eau et puis il y a également bien
évidemment un moyen terme une refonte
des investissements comme j'évoquais
tout à l'heure dans le cadre de la PPI
sur la vers la sortie des tours d'eau
avec un objectif donc de réalisation
notamment d'une usine de dessalement de
grande capacités sur grand air et une
accélération des investissements puisque
l'usine était prévue à l'horizon 2026 et
on accélère toutes les procédures pour
être en capacité de livrer une première
tranche de l'ordre de 10000 m3 jours
d'ici juillet 2024
voilà ce que je peux vous dire déjà en
première en première élément
bien merci je vais demander maintenant à
Monsieur façade Bada qui était en ligne
tout à l'heure
oui il est toujours avec nous et après
madame
inmode qui se prépare merci bonjour
bonjour
mesdames bonjour messieurs merci pour
votre invitation à participer à cette
cette mission donc le territoire de La
Réunion donc le territoire de La Réunion
île tropicale
2500 km2 860
000 habitants
donc zone interdical aujourd'hui par
rapport à la ressource en eau c'est une
île qui est très arrosée globalement
annuellement 7 milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau depuis tombent sur l'île de la
Réunion
la difficulté et les réalités
territoriales sont que en fonction du
moment dans l'année donc une saison des
pluies dans l'hémisphère sud qui
commence au mois de décembre et se
termine habituellement au mois d'avril
et saison des pluies qui constituent 80%
de la recharge de la ressource en eau et
une saison sèche donc sur le du mois de
juin jusqu'au mois de octobre novembre
ou c'est une période où ils vont il y
aurait des laitiers et on est plutôt en
tension on est en plutôt en tension par
rapport à l'accès à la ressource en eau
donc globalement pas de difficulté
localement
des difficultés peuvent apparaître
en fonction des territoires donc une
égale répartition spatiale et et dans le
temps également
par rapport au service public de et
d'assainissement avec la mise en œuvre
de la loi note au 1er janvier 2020
l'organisation du service public de
d'assainissement est passé d'une
vingtaine autour d'autorité
organisatrices à 5 et l'île de la
Réunion est couverte par 5 communautés
d'agglomération elles sont toutes
Aujourd'hui compétentes en matière de
potable d'assainissement
de j'ai Mappy et gestion des opus
urbaines
il vous a pas échappé donc les offices
de l'eau
dans les doms arrive 40 ans après la loi
de 1964 la loi sur l'autre 64 donc 40
ans après les agences de l'eau nous
avons des missions équivalentes
similaires nous avons également nos
propres spécificités
par rapport à
l'organisation territoriale de chaque
île à la Réunion existe également une
collectivité territoire régionale et une
collectivité départementale l'office de
leur réunion est rattaché au département
conformément à la loi
5 autorités organisatrices qui
aujourd'hui sont pleinement compétentes
en matière de potable et
d'assainissement alors très rapidement
un état des lieux 394
[Musique]
000 abonnés en eau potable
60 80% de la population aujourd'hui et
gérer en délégation de service public
à peu près 5906000 km de réseau donc
avec une des performances de l'ordre de
60 61% de rendement
un gros travail a été fait sur la
période
2016-2021 en ce qui concerne la
potabilisation et ça c'est l'enjeu le
premier enjeu par rapport à l'eau
potable c'est bien les rendements de
réseau le deuxième enjeu c'est bien le
traitement la potabilisation
26 unités de potabilisation en
fonctionnement aujourd'hui donc 18 créer
entre 2016 et 2021
encore prévus une quinzaine et
je pense à l'horizon 2030 2035 95% de la
population
disposera d'une eau maîtrisée H24
en ce qui concerne l'assainissement
le travail a commencé un peu plus tôt
que l'eau potable parce que entre 2009
et 2015 un gros efforts ont été fait en
matière d'investissement et notamment la
réhabilitation ou la création des
stations d'épuration aujourd'hui Lille
les couverte par 16 station d'épuration
collective
il représente à peu près 670
000 équivalents habitants et globalement
la capacité de traitement et est
suffisante pour les pollution la
pollution collectée
ponctuellement nous pouvons nous
retrouver sur dans quelques situations
de de non-conformité ou de saturation
mais globalement la capacité de
traitement et suffisante cette pollution
collectée c'est 1700 km de tuyau 1500 km
de réseau
assainissement collectif concerne à peu
près 45% de la population
ce qui veut dire que
45% de la population reste sont en
assainissement non collectif donc
dispositif fosse septique assainissement
individuel
175000 et en gros ça fait 175000
dispositifs avec un état des lieux très
insatisfaisant puisque pratiquement 90%
de ces dispositifs sont défaillants
aujourd'hui et c'est un vrai risque tant
par rapport à l'enjeu sanitaire que
l'enjeu environnementale
qu'est-ce que je peux dire encore par
rapport à cet état des lieux donc je
l'ai dit
spécificité également en outre-mer c'est
par rapport à la gouvernance c'est le
comité de l'eau et de la biodiversité
c'est-à-dire que nous avons aujourd'hui
sur notre territoire une seule instance
donc comité de base et qui existe en
métropole comité de bassin et comité de
régional de diversité donc il y a une
seule instance le Parlement de l'eau et
de la biodiversité qui est en place donc
depuis la loi biodive de 2016 donc c'est
pourquoi j'en parle c'est parce
qu'aujourd'hui le PPI de l'office de
l'eau et et
donné par et de les valider par le
comité de l'eau de la biodiversité et
cela peut avoir une incidence notamment
aujourd'hui par rapport aux actions
menées en matière des investissements
menés dans le cadre de l'eau potable et
du traitement des eaux usées et les
actions attendues en matière de
biodiversité
par rapport aux enjeux en lien sur
l'assainissement
les enjeux attendus aujourd'hui se
poursuivre poursuivre le traitement
notamment un assainissement non
collectif donc améliorer les dispositifs
mais également un sujet des raccords non
raccordés c'est-à-dire augmenter
augmenter le réseau de collecte
il y a également un sujet de pollution
diffuse donc les aires d'alimentation de
captage il y a également ce sujet donc
aires d'alimentation de captage à la
réunion dont 6 sont concernés power la
mobilisation de l'eau potable
et je terminerai en disant
qu'aujourd'hui de gros enjeux alors par
rapport à l'ingénierie
aujourd'hui il y a suffisamment l'outil
les outils financiers sont là les outils
financiers sont là nous arrivons à
mobiliser en le territoire de La Réunion
à peu près réussi à mettre en œuvre
entre 450 500 millions d'euros de
travaux sur 6 ans donc il est la période
du stage
mais nous constatons aujourd'hui une
certaine difficulté à sortir certains
projets du fait d'une insuffisance de
structuration des équipes ou des
compétences des équipes que ce soit en
matière de de potable de traitement des
eaux usées et de la gestion des milieux
aquatiques de la gemapi donc il y a
cette difficulté d'avoir des
collaborateurs compétents que ce soit en
collectivité mais également au bureau
d'études et c'est pour cela que nous
travaillons aujourd'hui dans le cadre du
Plan Odom nous travaillons donc avec les
services de l'État à
essayer de faire sortir des cursus de
formation spécifique alors il y aura le
sujet de la temporalité et entre le
moment où les ingénieurs sortiront il y
aura toujours des besoins donc voilà
donc voilà donc il y a ce gros travail
aujourd'hui qui est en oeuvre par
rapport aux questionnaires donc j'ai
bien on vous renverra donc les réponses
aux questions donc c'était juste une
première présentation de la situation de
la Réunion en ce qui concerne la
ressource en eau merci
madame Myriam inimode
bonjour vous m'entendez bien
oui très bien
la Guyane
quatre PC
plein de communes 4 PCI un seul PC avec
les compétences eau et assainissement et
un FPCI avec la compétence
assainissement non collectif
globalement on prélève sur la ressource
en eau environ 21 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau par an pour l'alimentation
en eau potable
donc 90% à partir de captage d'eau de
surface on a un exploitant historique
donc sur la pour une DSP délégation de
service public qui couvre quasiment
l'ensemble du territoire c'est 18
communes sur les 22 et 4 communes dites
en régies alors pudiquement le terme de
Régis est caché qui a aucune
structuration de service
on assainissement par contre il y a deux
exploitants pour les stations
d'épuration et les réseaux
le budget de l'office de l'eau et
environ 3,4 millions d'euros de recettes
issues des redevances
et une moyenne d'à peu près un million 4
de d'aide au porteur de projet donc on a
voté le PPI sur 7 ans à 9 millions 6
donc si je divise par 700 ça fait
globalement un million quatre par an ça
pour montrer la différence avec les
besoins du territoire
pour le cadre de l'étude de transfert
des compétences en lien avec la loi avec
la loi nôtre il échéance du 1er janvier
2026 les EPCI ont lancé des études qui
font la démonstration que la
mutualisation ça ne servent à communal
la mutualisation ne va pas se traduire
par une réduction des coûts
donc même si effectivement nous
assistons
nous incitons le transfert des
compétences devient obligatoire le
discours selon lequel cela permettra de
réduire les coûts ici il n'est pas
jouable puisqu'il n'y a pas au vu de
l'étendue du territoire il n'y a pas
forcément d'interprétion possible entre
les différentes communes d'un même PCI
mes collègues de Martinique et de
réunion disait que aujourd'hui il y a
des projets il y a pas de projet avec du
financement nous depuis un an à peu près
nous avons quatre gros projets je ne
connaissances que de quatre gros projets
lancés
est prêt à être lancé mais sans
financement
parce que il y a un gros financeur l'OSB
l'Office français de la biodiversité qui
a changé ses règles d'attribution qui ne
finance plus par exemple des réservoirs
de stockage
qui fait en sorte qu'on a deux projets
sur les quatre qui sont bloqués à cause
de ça on arrive les communes n'arrivent
pas à boucler leurs plans de financement
concernant le plan gomme à l'office de
l'eau nous avons crois ingénieurs qui
accompagnent les communes au plus près
et on a mené en fait un partenariat avec
les collectivités vous les accompagner
sur leurs projets ou et assainissement
et on travaille en étroite collaboration
à charger une mission de des EPCI donc
la CCOG qui couvre 8 communes sur les 22
et qui couvent en termes de superficie
la plus grande partie du territoire
guyanais
et une chose à laquelle je
insisterai si le fait de dire que
l'étude de transfert dans le savais déjà
avant la conclusion c'est que Lola paie
pas l'eau il faut absolument que les
communiser de Guyane réfléchir à un
autre mode de financement des services
publics puisque même quand on aura la
compétence intercommunale on ne va pas
régler enfin l'eau ne va toujours pas
payer l'eau donc on a on a eu des
sollicités il y a quelques temps sur des
évolutions réglementaires et législatifs
nous c'est l'un des points sur lesquels
on souhaite assister avant même des
évolutions techniques de dispositif pour
revenir sur la situation de
l'assainissement
90% selon les deux sports intercommunaux
90% du parc d'assainissement non
collectif serait non conforme donc nous
aussi nous avons un dispositif d'aide
aux particuliers qui est très maigre et
en comparaison de celui de l'office de
Martinique on a qu'un million 7
pour aider les
usagers de deux OPCI
voilà globalement jeter les premiers
éléments sur la Guyane
bien merci merci
Hervé gilet reprend la parole notre
rapporteur oui merci beaucoup pour vos
présentations qui présentaient aussi la
situation un état des lieux peut-être si
vous voulez bien on va on va rebondir
sur et approfondir quelques sujets en
reprenant peut-être l'ordre de passage
mais sur des interventions plus
resserrées pour nous permettre de
tourner rapidement ce que j'aimerais
savoir c'est tout d'abord que vous me
donniez des éléments au niveau du modèle
économique et financier le coût mètre
cube bien sûr
eau et assainissement quand vous êtes
effectivement en collectif la question
complémentaire aussi au programme
d'investissement vous avez pu citer
c'est l'évaluation au niveau des besoins
c'est-à-dire qu'elle décalage vous avez
dans la capacité aujourd'hui de mettre
en œuvre un programme d'investissement
des programmes d'investissement et les
besoins réels donc aujourd'hui
faut-il faire appel à d'autres
interventions financières je crois qu'il
y a eu d'ailleurs des engagements pour
certains d'entre vous au niveau
gouvernemental peut-être que vous
pourrez nous les préciser vous faites
états donc tous de niveau de non
conformité relativement important même
s'il y a des
différences entre vous
sur pour vous quel serait la meilleure
trajectoire pour essayer de diminuer ces
taux de nos conformités notamment sur le
Non Collectif
y a-t-il possibilité de mutualiser
des coûts d'intervention puisque les
unités d'usage les unités d'habitation
compte tenues de leur situation
sociale et professionnelle ne peuvent
pas faire face à ces coups là est-ce
qu'il y aurait des possibilités de
mutualiser à un moment donné les coûts
pour pouvoir effectivement intervenir
est-ce d'ailleurs un des actes du
dispositif
des femmes dont vous avez parlé à un
moment donné sur ses capacités
d'intervention et puis en profitant de
vos réponses quels seraient les
propositions vous pourriez nous faire
dans le cadre de la mission qui serait
susceptible d'améliorer
la prise en charge de ces compétences à
votre échelle on reprend le tour de
table si vous voulez bien merci on va
peut-être parce qu'il va falloir qu'on
puisse faire ça de façon synthétique
parce que j'ai encore mes collègues qui
vont vous poser d'autres questions et là
il y a une série de questions assez
importante donc merci de lever la main
pour celui qui veut prendre la parole
peut-être qu'on va pas pouvoir
prendre la parole sur chacun sur toutes
les mêmes questions parce que ça va être
à mon avis trop long donc si on peut
peut-être tourner entre les uns et les
autres madame
prends la parole et après une autre
personne
oui je fais très rapidement sur le
dispositif des faps
donc il y a un certain une enveloppe qui
est quand même assez assez conséquente
mais qui n'est pas encore consommé
moi je dirais vous nous demandez vous
nous interpellez sur le fait de
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
améliorer le taux de non conformité sur
le Non Collectif premièrement
un battage c'est ce que nous faisons de
sensibilisation de la population en gros
que les personnes puissent la population
puisse être en conscience et pas la
population seulement les élus également
en Martinique ça commence on commence à
avoir ce débat là tout le monde était
concentré sur l'eau potable
et nous soulignons avec satisfaction que
les élus petit à petit s'empare de ce
sujet donc sensibiliser la population
qu'ils comprennent bien que ils ont un
impact direct sur les la pollution
avec un impact sanitaire et
environnemental deuxièmement c'est
l'argent le financement
on a un de financement majeur
des plombiers existent nous avons réussi
à l'office de l'eau Martinique à
aggloméré un certain nombre de ponts de
plombier les former les sensibiliser
maintenant on a une question financière
et
nous proposons nous d'aller vers des
solutions
d'aide d'aide à la population en passant
par des aides sociales ou des aides du
type chèque énergie ou ce qu'on a pu
faire sur d'autres politiques
comment de d'étanchéité des choses comme
ça on pourrait imaginer des dispositifs
similaires et troisièmement accompagner
les OPCI dans la prise de compétences et
au moins sur par exemple dans un premier
temps la compétence entretient de la de
l'ANC c'est vrai que ça a un coût mais
peut-être que ça permettrait déjà de
répondre à cette problématique
d'entretien
de faire en sorte que ces dispositifs
fonctionnent il y a un EPCI en
Martinique qui est en réflexion dessus
et c'est encore une fois une
problématique financière je m'arrête là
il y a peut-être d'autres les collègues
vont répondre sur d'autres questions
mais moi c'était sur l'assainissement
non collectif que je voulais faire part
de nos propositions
merci qui veut répondre sur d'autres
questions
pardon et enfin juste enfin peut-être
faire évoluer le texte qui qui pense la
conformité de manière générique toute la
France confondue alors que en Martinique
ou dans les outre-mer il y a parfois
certaines installations rustiques qui
peuvent fonctionner avec juste une
complétude et qui ne nécessite pas
forcément une réhabilitation totale
faire évoluer la législation nous avons
fait des propositions dans ce sens merci
merci
qui monsieur Laban
allez
expérimente un dispositif qui fonctionne
sur l'assainissement collectif on a
annoncé des appels à projets en
direction des bailleurs sociaux et donc
on a réussi à avoir des résultats qui
sont pas spectaculaires mais plus on
avance parce que nous on a fait un lien
entre
l'exploitation du service public de
l'eau de l'assainissement et la
dégradation des milieux et le constat
est éclaire au sujet de l'assainissement
donc les appels un projet avec les
bailleurs sociaux ça fonctionne donc on
les développe et on les multiplie mais
c'est une goutte d'eau dans l'océan
on a eu nous depuis déjà 5 ans un
effondrement du recouvrement de nous
redevance on est dans une situation très
compliquée mais malgré ça on a dans
notre budget décliné une intention
auprès de l'opérateur unique de remettre
en conformité les
attestation de plus de 2000 équivalents
habitants donc il y en a 18 il y en a 14
qui sont pas conformes donc on veut être
tonique sur des financements office de
la remise en conformité des grosses
stations d'épuration et sur
l'assainissement non collectif
on a essayé de trouver des partenaires
sociaux mais je vous cache pas que la
situation est compliquée parce que la
CAF fait la caisse de sécurité sociale
nous ont fait savoir que le Market
financière était entièrement mobilisé
sur le lien social et
les actions prioritaires en direction de
des publics défavorisés et donc ils ne
seront pas du moins dans l'immédiat en
capacité de nous aider
chose ce que nous souhaitons nous c'est
que le système fonctionne parce que on
est à 55 millions d'euros de créances
non recouvrée donc le
système de la redevance de marche pas on
va devoir à 9000 valeurs au volume
conséquent de redevance nous manquer
c'est par l'office pour deux raisons je
vous les ai expliqué tout à l'heure il y
a un usage abusif de la ressource on
prélève 120 millions d'euros de 120
millions de mètres cubes d'eau on monte
à la moitié et s'ajoute à ça un taux de
recouvrement dans la facturation qui est
de 40%, ce qui fait que les titres que
nous émettons nous serons jamais honorés
puisque
les effets cumulés de suite et du
non-règlement des factures
réduisent de 30% le pourcentage de
volume de re parce qu'on peut prélever
en soi alors on a un offre toutes les
exigences révélé provisions pour des
tribunaux avec la chambre régionale des
comptes ça me donne rien donc notre
système s'effondre et donc on essaie de
le sauver en négociant avec le nouvel
opérateur
un accord sur un état allemand de vente
mais au moins les payer
on s'est rendu compte que les opérateurs
privés payent leur redevance donc le
système fonctionne on a un opérateur
privé sur Marie-Galante qui qui respecte
ces engagements et donc on aurait
diminué à voir votre soutien pour que le
règlement de la redevance soit appliqué
comme dans toutes les régions de
métropole
par rapport à cette situation dégradée
on ne lâche pas l'affaire j'aurais
tendance à dire que ce qu'on souhaite
nous c'est que effectivement il y a un
déficit d'ingénierie mais qu'on puisse
simplifier les procédures et que dans la
mesure du possible en plus prendre une
partie de l'ingénierie qui fait des
choses opérateurs de manière à ce qu'on
accélère la politique de rattrapage dont
le rétablissement de la performance des
réseaux et dont le rétablissement de
dispositif d'assainissement conforme
parce que la dégradation des milieux
elle est évident et s'amplifie donc ce
sont pour nous des urgences
incontournables
si quelqu'un d'autre veut prendre de
répondre aux questions de notre
apporteur monsieur Bada oui merci
donc par rapport aux quatre questions
que le modèle économique donc à la
Réunion le prix du mètre cube eau
potable assainissement c'est entre 2,40
et 2,50 € le mètre cube
c'est très faible
c'est un coup c'est un coup qui est
inférieur à certains certains coups qui
seront en compte ailleurs mais il faut
aussi qu'obtenir compte de la situation
socio-économique de la Réunion donc
aujourd'hui et du fait des
investissements qui sont programmés et
qui sont en train de
potabilisation avant les unités
d'épuration mécaniquement le la
tarification va augmenter
par rapport au redevance aujourd'hui sur
le bassin réunion avec l'ensemble des
redevances
88% de ces redevances affectent la
facture d'eau justement
l'ordre de grandeur c'est 11 millions
d'euros par an ce qui concerne l'office
de l'Office de la Réunion
sur le sujet de est-ce que il y a on
fait suffisamment par rapport aux
besoins existants là par rapport alors
moi c'est très simple je le dis tout à
l'heure nous avons la capacité de
programmation du territoire c'est entre
450 et 550 millions d'euros sur six
années
oui le besoin il est peut-être plus
grand il est peut-être de le milliard
d'euros parce qu'on entend on entend ces
chiffres j'ai besoin d'investissement ou
assainissement on entend souvent ces
chiffres du milliard le sujet pour nous
c'est qu'est-ce que c'est ce qu'on est
capable de faire dans un temps imparti
et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
globalement les ressources financières
sont à disposition il y a et donc il
faut être capable de programmer avec un
petit jeu nuances très cependant un
petit bémol je rebondis sur ce qu'a dit
la directrice de l'office de l'autre
Guyane il faut avoir une certaine
agilité des dispositifs financiers entre
les assistants les dispositifs portés
par l'OSB le dispositif porté par la
région au niveau du FEDER les
dispositifs de l'État que sont le désir
le FEI il faut garder cette certaine et
bien sûr les interventions de l'office
de l’eau il faut avoir une certaine une
certaine agilité une certaine facilité
pour que les porteurs de projets
puissent mobiliser réellement puisse
engager réellement les fonds je vous
donne un exemple à l'office de l'eau le
PPI de l'ozoide financière donc nous
avons quatre orientations 4 enveloppes
toutes ces quatre enveloppes sont
fongibles par exemple donc comme ça en
cours d'exécution s'il y a dans un signe
orientation manque un petit peu de
ressources on peut tout de suite faire
le travail et prendre sur les autres
donc avoir cette agilité de mécanisme
financier
sur la conformité oui oui à la Réunion
et notamment en assainissement de non
collectifs justement dans notre pays
2022-2027 nous avons souhaité faire
émerger des opérations collectives sur
la réhabilitation des dispositifs AMC
c'est-à-dire les mettre les dispositifs
NC sont bien déprivés mais nous avons
souhaité impliquer également l'autorité
organisatrice dans la réhabilitation
donc essayer de faire émerger des
opérations collectives donc venir en
financement sur les opérations
collectives ce n'est pas facile pour que
ça commence à se faire avec une
communauté d'agglomération donc on
attend de voir et parmi les propositions
je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
certain nombre d'outils à disposition la
difficulté c'est de les mettre en
application donc la loi 3DS par exemple
impermé un certain nombre de choses je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut voilà il
faut aussi que les autorites
organisatrices mais elles y donc je
pense on a notre territoire font à part
parfois un peu spécifiques il y a un
sujet on reviendra peut-être après qui
se rencontrer plus en métropole c'est
petit territoire
français région ultra-féérique autour
dans un océan avec des étapes des états
des pays autour de nous il peut y avoir
un sujet de d'Hydro diplomatie de l'eau
donc ça il peut y avoir un petit sujet
et notamment par Marion pour s'en parler
que moi mais avec parfois des des crises
migratoires du fait de la situation de
la ressource en eau
merci
Monsieur Kramer veut peut-être répondre
à
aux dernières questions après il y a
Micheline Jacques qui a une question
oui je vais je vais compléter les propos
effectivement qui qui ont été dit donc
sur le
sur les financements notamment je ferai
un petit accès spécifique puisque
ça a été dit il y a de nombreuses
sources de financement qui sont
mobilisables on a effectivement les
fonds européens sur lequel on peut on
peut travailler donc qui font l'objet du
de la programmation du programme
européen donc
qui est en cours on a également là on va
rentrer dans les discussions justement
de nous côté état avec les collectivités
et les autres Coyotes sur la partie
contrat de plan et ta région avec les
nouvelles enveloppes qui vont nous être
défini et les mandats qui vont nous être
donnés pour cette partie là il y a
également des financements donc de l'ovp
avec des critères qui leur sont
spécifiques donc et qui sont
complémentaires sur lequel on peut aussi
travailler et
tout a volé notamment sur Mayotte
d'accompagnement avec des
de la part de l'AFD qui sont des prix
qui permet justement de lancer les les
opérations et qui sont des pré en
pré-financement de certains projets qui
qui sont nécessaires ici au territoire
pour être en capacité de pouvoir réussir
à tenir la PPI et les montants
d'investissement que vous avez que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure sur l'ensemble de
la zone que ce soit en eau potable ou en
assainissement dessus donc effectivement
l'objectif chez nous c'est de mutualiser
un petit peu tous ces financements et
d'essayer d'être en capacité
de disposer ce que disait effectivement
sur la date d'une certaine souplesse sur
l'adaptation de ses financements
éviter qu'il soit trop fléchés sur tel
ou tel type d'opération parce que d'une
part on peut se retrouver avec des
décalages dans les réalisateurs
d'opération et d'autre part on a les
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est la situation
actuelle sur Mayotte c'est à dire on est
dans une situation de crise actuellement
et donc on a une nécessité de pouvoir
mobiliser très très rapidement des
financements et des préfinancement qu'on
peut mettre en place sur le sur le
territoire voilà ce que je pourrais
ajouter très rapidement
merci je vais demander à Micheline
Jacques sénatrice de Saint-Barthélémy
qui a une question ou plusieurs
questions d'ailleurs une série de
questions
merci Président Monsieur collègues
mesdames Messieurs Je vous remercie pour
la qualité de vos interventions qui ont
été très éclairantes j'ai noté une
certaine inquiétude sur la raréfaction
de la ressource tant lié à au
réchauffement climatique parfois
certaines pollutions ou les Sargasses la
question que je souhaiterais vous poser
c'est avez-vous seriez-vous ouvert à
d'autres technologies innovantes en
matière de de production d'eau potable
et notamment une technologie qui
commence à pointer et qui commence à
émerger qui qui est le l'eau
atmosphérique comme nous sommes les
territoires ultramarins sont des
territoires avec une une une forte
humidité atmosphérique donc que
pensez-vous de ces technologies et
seriez-vous prêt à les expérimenter dans
les dans vos territoires et j'aurais
aimé savoir aussi ce que vous pensez des
des projets de territoire de la de la
gestion de l'eau puisque ce sont des
dispositifs qui existent en France
hexagonale est-ce difficile de les
mettre en oeuvre sur les territoires
ultramarins et pensez-vous que ce serait
des dispositifs qui seraient pertinents
à mettre en place dans ces dans les
territoires
bien qui veut répondre aux questions de
Micheline
il suffit de lever la main Monsieur
Madame
par rapport les solutions techniques
aujourd'hui donc et le volet un peu
d'innovation et le recours donc à les
capter l'eau atmosphérique je pense que
c'est à partir du moment où la situation
l'exige il faudra donc
une situation de stress hydrique ou de
l'insuffisance d'accès à une ressource
en eau que ce soit les nappes ou les
rivières
oui je pense que c'est possible d'y
aller on peut aller sur ce volet là
après il faut aussi être pragmatique et
ce qui a été fait jusqu'à aujourd'hui
c'est d'aller dans la situation la plus
favorable d'aller rechercher l'eau dans
un contexte le plus le plus favorable
possible aujourd'hui dans le contexte en
tout cas de la réunion à part les
tirages donc à part le mois d'octobre
septembre octobre aujourd'hui
il y a une on n'est pas encore à ce
stade là il y a peut-être d'autres
techniques tu vas peut-être arriver
avant peut-être mais il risque d'être
confrontés à l'enjeu d'énergie et
notamment le le ou le coup le coup de
l'énergie sur les outils tels que le
ptge donc aujourd'hui à la Réunion
n'existe pas le PG en place il peut y
avoir il peut y avoir besoin
la difficulté donc je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure depuis 2020 les autorités
organisatrices à des comités de
communication sont compétents mais elles
encore un peu de mal à mon sens de
prendre pleinement leurs compétences et
tout ce qui est en lien avec les
dynamiques territoriales l'animation
territoriale il va falloir voilà il va
falloir continuer à aller travailler
continuer à à améliorer
[Musique]
le fait qu'elle se réveille dans ce sens
je reviendrai sur les aides alimentation
de Carthage par exemple donc on a
aujourd'hui une douzaine de captages
prioritaires on a commencé à travailler
avec les autorités organisatrices et les
professionnels de l'agriculture à mettre
en place donc une sorte de dynamique
territoriale c'est un peu de mal c'est
un peu de mal à y aller donc il faut les
accompagner il faut relancer il faut
voilà je pense que sur le PTG je pense
que c'est aujourd'hui il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas de péter jeux en cours c'est
la difficulté que je pense que
j'identifie à ce stade
qui veut compléter la réponse alors je
me suis montjo qui n'avait pas pris la
parole et puis après monsieur Kremer
assez de façon synthétique si parce que
je pense qu'il y en a qui veulent
peut-être partir dans
parmi vous et bon je veux pas abuser de
votre temps
on vous entend pas monsieur bonjour
monsieur Kremer
on entend pas monsieur Mangeot mais
allez-y monsieur Kremer
très rapidement pour répondre à ma
sénatrice alors effectivement nous on a
regardé justement
toute la partie technologique avec
atmosphérique pour essayer de voir si ça
pouvait être une solution sur sur
Mayotte face à la crise actuelle c'est
une solution qu'on a je dirais un peu
écarté pour l'instant pourquoi parce que
la production d'eau reste relativement
faible par rapport aux besoins qu'on
peut avoir sur le territoire de mémoire
les unités qu'on nous a présentées
c'était 180 000 litres d'eau par an
maximum alors que les besoins sont
beaucoup plus importants avec une forte
consommation d'électricité pour autant
c'est une technologie qu'on regarde
c'est une technologie à mon avis qui
sera mature très certainement d'ici peu
de temps ou qui peut répondre à des
besoins ponctuels qu'on peut avoir sur
sur certains territoires
puis j'étais aussi pour répondre très
rapidement nous on regarde de manière
très très
fine ce qui se passe actuellement sur la
Corse voilà
est-ce que Monsieur Mangeot a retrouvé
son micro
j'ai changé de micro est-ce que vous
m'entendez des effets
alors oui pour répondre d'abord sur les
technologies innovantes comme la
captation des eaux atmosphériques
c'est quelque chose qui se faisait
traditionnellement sur les petites îles
sans Caraïbes notamment on observe
encore des impuriums qui captent sur les
effets Grenadines nous en Martinique ce
n'est pas pour l'instant une voie
d'expérimentation étant donné que la
plupart du temps on a on a suffisamment
de ressources
par contre on essaye quand même pour
aller vers la sobriété d'aller vers des
usages dont nos conventionnels et on a
notamment étudié le potentiel de Ré
en particulier en agriculture mais on
travaille également sur le potentiel de
récupération des eaux usées des eaux
pluviales que ce soit à l'échelle des
entreprises des domestiques il y a
plusieurs il y a des études et des
dispositifs de financement je vous
enverraient les éléments dans le cadre
du questionnaire
concernant le ptgen effectivement le
dispositifs nous en Martinique on a eu
une approche
nous visons à essayer de planifier la
gestion de la ressource à l'échelle de
l'île on a développé un modèle de
gestion d'aller à la ressource qui allie
des conditions climatiques
environnementales avec
le
dispositifs d'infrastructures et
également les besoins des différents
usages et ce dispositif nous permet de
simuler des scénarios d'aménagement à
l'aune de variations de changement
climatique qui est aggravation des
sécheresses et on a pu chiffrer déjà le
coût de l'inaction avec les pertes les
pertes de l'usage diverses et variés
l'achat doit en bouteille etc et puis
des scénarios
combinés
d'amélioration des rendements de mise en
place de nouvelles ressources de
diversification de la ressource
d'interconnexion et on se rend compte
que la solution
la plus efficace c'est une solution qui
l'ensemble des interventions donc on
arrive on a comme ça une feuille de
route macro pour pour le territoire qui
nous permet
d'aller vers une gestion durable de la
ressource et c'est ce modèle il est
utilisé actuellement par les autres pays
pour le développement de leur schéma
directeur d'alimentation
et puis je me permets de donner aussi
une information
concernant les questions précédentes le
coût du service d'eau en Martinique pour
l'eau potable seule c'est 2,73 euros en
moyenne sur le territoire et pour avec
l'assainissement on monte à 2,71 donc un
coup de service très fort on a plus de
marge de manœuvre du tout
pour trouver des recettes du côté de
l'augmentation du service
bien merci merci pour ces réponses il y
a pas d'autres demandes de parole parce
que je voudrais des laisser la parole
aussi à notre président de la délégation
des Outre-mer Stéphane Artano qui
pourrait peut-être nous dire un petit
mot de pot de conclusion parce qu'il y a
jamais de conclusion à tout cela il y a
encore beaucoup beaucoup de travail à
faire et d'ailleurs on compte sur vos
contributions écrites si vous avez un
moment pour nous les envoyer pour la
famille début juin pour qu'on puisse
finaliser notre rapport merci à vous
merci monsieur le président
le rapporteur merci d'avoir associé les
membres de la délégation sénatale aux
outre-mer à ce travail important sur la
gestion durable de l'eau et notamment
avec ce regard ultramarin j'ai évoqué ce
matin devant certains collègues LR
puisque j'étais invité à venir échanger
sur le volet ultramarin sur le fait que
finalement la politique de l'eau ça fait
partie me semble-t-il des piliers en
outre-mer sur lesquels les politiques
publiques de nous par nos concitoyens
sont jugés c'est un des sujets criants
sur lesquels un certain nombre d'élus
sont mis à défaut en outre-mer et la
parole publique et la capacité de
l'action publique et mise en défaut au
regard notamment les taux de rendement
et des non conformités que vous évoquez
tous les uns et les autres et je ne
jette la pierre à personne je fais un
constat objectif
et c'est vrai que on est on touche là
vraiment à un new gordien quand même de
l'action publique en outre-mer
et j'étais un peu atterré quand même de
constater que certains élus commencent à
en prendre conscience j'ai presque envie
de dire ça devrait être sur le radar
quotidien
systématique c'est quand même un des
services fondamentaux que nous devons
nous populations et il est vraiment
indispensable que tous les élus et cette
conscience cette conscience collective
par ailleurs vous avez évoqué de manière
à peu près transversale le fait que
globalement je parle bien globalement
que les financements sont plutôt
disponibles que notamment le regard de
l'état est quand même plutôt
bienveillant parce qu'il y a une
nécessité notamment de régler les noms
les non conformités et de pouvoir régler
tous les sujets qui sont inhérents à
chacun de vos réseaux qu'ils soient
hauts ou assainissement
mais en réalité il y a une problématique
d'ingénierie que vous avez tous soulevée
et vraiment là aussi la question d'aller
chercher l'ingénierie y compris à
l'extérieur du territoire auprès
d'opérateurs rodé à ce type d'exercices
me paraît être indispensable si on n'a
pas encore constitué des équipes sur nos
territoires puisque je viens de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon on peut avoir
le même type de dispositif et quand on
n'a pas la compétence en ton absolu sur
la construction d'un réseau par exemple
on va la chercher à l'extérieur et
vraiment cette question de l'ingénierie
pose également la question de
l'intervention de la NCT en outre-mer et
du dimensionnant de cette agence qui
pour la plupart du temps en fait
sont représentants est plutôt le préfet
des territoires et en réalité il y a pas
de service nouveau qui peuvent aider les
petites collectivités je parle bien des
petites collectivités ou des petits EPCI
qui pourraient solliciter des Expertis
dont ils ne bénéficie pas en interne
donc vraiment pour moi a priorité
absolue en termes de
prise de conscience collective de la
part de nos collègues élus et je le dis
avec vraiment beaucoup de gravité parce
que les choses vont bouger le jour ou
des élus vont être envoyés en
correctionnels je le dis aussi librement
parce que vous aurez des PV de concert
d'infraction de pollution des sols je
pense que vous avez assez de cœur
d'école je pense notamment à la
Martinique puisque là c'est là où ça a
été en particulier mais pas que et puis
derrière la question de l'ingénierie à
structurer vraiment ça doit faire partie
me semble-t-il des réponses également
que le gouvernement peut être amené à
vous apporter on soutient des
collectivités mais ce sont pour moi deux
sujets fondamentaux prise de conscience
et construction d'une ingénierie parce
que visiblement les volontés quand je
vous entends tous et toutes les volontés
sont présentes vous avez des schémas en
place vous avez des plans
d'investissement plus réels et donc il y
a j'ai presque envie de dire tous les
ingrédients sont quasiment réunis pour
que ça fonctionne mieux pour que
notamment les non conformités soient
réglés et vraiment si l'intérêt de cette
de cette mission c'est de mettre un
focus sur sur les particularités
outre-mer ça peut être le coût moindre
par exemple du mètre cube mais qui
peuvent aussi s'expliquer vous l'avez
dit notamment à la Réunion par la
situation
sociale de nos territoires les taux de
chômage extrêmement élevés l'inflation
des multipliée par rapport à l'Hexagone
malgré tout il y a quand même des
solutions techniques qui me semblent
pouvoir vous être apportées pour vous
permettre de remplir pleinement vos
missions quand vous vous sentez en
travée en tout cas merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le rapporteur
de ce regard
ultramarin encore fort utile pour mieux
comprendre également les contraintes de
nos territoires respectifs avec plaisir
bien écoutez en tout cas je sais pas si
Hervé tu veux ajouter un mot non
Président je pense qu'on a fait
globalement le tour d'un certain nombre
d'enjeux
le président également Artano a resitué
à quelques sujets qui sont vraiment
absolument essentiels l'ingénierie et
l'ingénierie territoriale la capacité à
faire et à mettre en œuvre et vraiment
une question de fond nous allons aussi
essayer la de la travailler de notre
côté parce que elle semble absolument
essentielle pour vous aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir vous accompagner et vous
permettre de réaliser dans des
conditions correctes c'est vraiment de
toute évidence au travers de cette
audition une question de fond qui doit
aussi nous interroger au niveau de nos
travaux et de nos propositions donc
merci encore pour ce échanges et puis
bien évidemment on a sans doute pas pu
tout aborder mais nous vous laissons
soin de nous apporter aussi des
éclairages complé faire que nous
n'aurions pas éventuellement évoqué dans
le cadre de cet échange qui était très
intéressant merci
en tout cas merci à vous pour votre
disponibilité avec des horaires assez
disparate entre vous
je crois qu'il doit être 21h 30 à la
Réunion
13h30 à Pointe-à-Pitre c'est ça non et
20h à Mayotte
21h je sais pas nous il est il est il
est bientôt 20h chez nous bientôt 14h
et 22 en tout cas de cette visio c'est
c'est bien passé sur le plan technique
et je remercie bien sûr notre
administration qui a été bienveillante
sur cette visio merci à vous merci merci
à bientôt
au revoir bon courage merci